thank you to Rocky money and hello fresh
for sponsoring this video more on them
after the reaction
[Music]
peeps citizens of the reject Nation it
is time for Reacher season 2 episode 2
and three we're going to cover both of
them back to back today John how you
doing I am ready to knel Lee at the
altar of Reacher baby I think that's
fine anyway guys hey why don't you go
ahead and tell us Bel what are you
thinking about feure season 2 thus far
if you're here watching it this video
that means you've already seen these
three episodes so let us know in the
comments what you guys are thinking and
also hey leave a like while you're at it
that would be extremely appreciative
also subscribe click the notification
Bell get notified when reaction for
episode 4 is up here on the Chanel and
thank you to prepper for helping us edit
down these reaction highlights and as
always fulling reaction watching along
res single with your own copy of Reacher
that is available for our super sexy
rejects over at our patreon page over
there John I cover several shows
exclusively with the reaction highlights
and watch songs included let's get into
action
people so if someone's coming after the
110 how come they haven't made it run at
the three of us yet you in the woods
with your family no one can ever find me
and maybe they just hadn't gotten around
a NE yet damn it neie I'll call Sanchez
and Orosco I got texed there's a black
sedan across the street couple houses
down same one as yesterday people just
buy black s Dan we being followed how
you want to play this I'm going to go
introduce myself
hi I'm Jack who are you I normally don't
talk to
strangers I don't like to get involved
what you think he's going to
do
yeah like a brick wall needs to hit the
right spot you know
man wow
gun T
oh just like the good old
days yeah you w the sidelines while I I
do all the
work don't look at me you did all the
work and now we're going to have
boatloads of paperwork to do gotta say
man major screw up soon as Russo wakes
up the entire NYPD is going to be after
your right why'd you got to hit him so
hard huh yeah I was pissed about the dog
and I assumed he was involved in killing
frony and Swan what did you teach us in
an investigation assumptions kill and
they make asses out of you and me he's
the investigating officer in France's
homicide I saw in the files oh NYPD saw
the calls France made to you flagged
your name got an alert when you bought
the plane ticket it's been on you since
you landed question is why yeah it's
your fault when I called Sanchez in
aros's Office voicemail was full might
not be a bad time to get out of Dodge
considering cocky bboa here just knocked
out a law man we'll head down to
Atlantic City see if we can find the
guys maybe they'll make a wanted poster
of you guys wait I don't understand was
it a car accident no you just kicked the
car I'm telling you this guy's a beast
time comes I'm going to need some backup
and you'll get it you just stay on their
asses and don't this up yeah sh's going
to pick up a car by the end of this
season something just got so much more
R-rated we don't have a choice we're
flagged in the system we can't rent
anything under our names oh we drive
around a stolen vehicle we just get
pinched what do you see I've got our
solution I think so going a Chili Palmer
this
Seducer that was your undercover
job Reacher how' you know I was
undercover considering the circumstances
you would have come right away you
didn't which can only mean you didn't
get our messages until recently if you
were on vacation you would have checked
in with your office
periodically deep undercover or frequent
check-ins aren't always possible same
old
Prater oh my God there's a romance
between them still got your fake ID with
you yeah use it to rent the car what's
with all the secrecy El O'Donnell and I
have been flagged in the system and I
punched out a
cop of course he did that's so hot I
love when you do that make sure you get
an SUV I know you need the head room
yeah the rental car lady better not mess
with the special
investigators oh man he definitely has a
thing for her still yeah a commanding
officer at a base in Afghanistan thinks
someone's stealing aviation fuel
siphoning off gas to resell it on the
side genius see I don't think anybody's
stealing and reselling anything take a
look at these numbers every time fuel
went missing from the base it was always
after a specific flight ooh Epstein I
mean it's a minor detail but in an
investigation Details
Matter I like that that's where he got
it from oh Origins Jack details there's
been no indication of Black Market fuel
sales anywhere on or around the base so
how does all that fuel go missing best
way to make gas disappears to burn it up
yeah where are they flying when those
planes land the amount of fuel in the
tanks is exactly what what's expected
that gets locked into the books so how
does that happen someone siphons at
mid-flight the excess fuel is being used
to transport more weight that people
realize is on the plane oh something
heavy and secret is being moved UFOs
exactly Contraband in the Humes drugs
guns stolen cash all of the above nfts
good work Dixon you just found a case
worthy of our attention
Dixon in oh
Jack go celebrate you buy me a drink
bench press me I got to keep working on
these
reports wow dude come
on excellent work Dixon yeah no problem
wow like I said numbers always tell the
story so forward and you just shut that
[__] down nah man like it was a
Jehovah's Witness at your front
door like it was a telemarketer call
my long distance is fine
so telling you a
story aome Kingdom story maybe the
numbers represent hard quantities like
eight out of 10 something not just four
or something beyond that two things
stick out none of these are 100% meaning
There's No 9 out of N9 or 10 out of 10
uhoh the first four pages have 26
numbers the fifth has 27 and the last
two have 26 again they're all movie
reviews what about James bar I mean that
guy's got the skills and the screw yeah
can't picture him throwing someone out
of a helicopter plus I ran into him in
Indiana last year he owes me now he call
in a favor there's no blue station we're
in
Jersey seems so sad I know he just wants
to learn about the blues sad Reacher a
they're headed towards Atlantic City
probably going to try to find their
missing buddies all in the same place at
once you remember what I said said about
needing backup I know some local talent
bring in whoever you need hold auditions
I just want them dead by tomorrow [__]
dead
o Robert Patrick thinks he's in some be
movie shoe
yeah that's a once in a-lifetime
inflection right
there every place rans sacked did they
find what they were looking for were
they mad just like France's office and
our hotel rooms he said they hadn't
trashed Swan's Place add that to the
list of things that must mean something
it trashed it almost exactly the same
way yeah
methodically am I the only one of us
that doesn't have this photo yep got
mine got mine on my
bookshelf where you next a bar look at
these photos with Sanchez and this woman
uh-oh who under 50 frames photos we do
but she's framed so she's important
we're going to the Lucky Lounge I like
that Reacher has a team and I like the
chemistry at the same time I am like I
would like the personalities and the
deliv the lines to be a little bit more
distinguishable feels a little bit more
like a detective procedural than than
like a character mystery I don't feel
like the lines given to them distinguish
their personalities enough yeah that's a
good that's a good way to put it it's
like they got the Rhythm but it's the
actual specific of the
lines four working a
day moreen hey do uhoh this guys say
their friends of Sanchez want to talk to
Molina take him back to the
office take him back to the office and
beat the [__] out of them we got this
this is going to go well we're in
control this is our
turf damn every they walk there's just
like organized
crime oh or they're just protecting her
is that the girl from the photo oh [__]
yep hey I just want to get a medium
mer pleas my order I just want to check
what's going on fellas you guys are
going to stop coming around here messing
with our friends look pal you somehow
got oh it's like a smack almost guys
it's just clearly a misunderstanding
there's not to beat the [__] out
they think you're someone
else
ooo like try and explain at least whoa
dog it's a good thing o'donell and I
didn't go in something could have gone
wrong it still did making friends big
fella he's still not doing [__] that guy
I know he's just chilling my guys were
just looking out for me scar dude came
in here asking for about a week ago said
he was working with s Sanchez and AOS
going some big security jobs we got a
fight scene it's fine yeah it's fine not
what we came here
for you wanted to know if Sanchez had
left any kind of digital storage device
with me I got a bad vibe off the guy so
as soon as he left I called horor he
didn't answer oh no you tried asking
France about this we can't why not
someone threw him out of a helicopter
yeah wow just revealing information this
is why you don't have a photo Jack
yeah no chill no tact tact Reacher last
time I saw H he was sitting on that
stool right there he got a call seemed
important he repeated a couple numbers
kind of like he was surprised by them or
or worried maybe oh do you remember the
numbers yeah 650 at 100K each no idea
what he meant by that you're sure that's
what he said oh I think it's a code you
remember the last word someone who left
said
[Music]
te hey they all communicate in these
money amounts Sanchez and Rosco do
freelance Casino security I mean maybe
it all started with them they stumbled
onto something big they needed help so
they reached out to France maybe Swan
guess this whole thing could be tied to
gaming follow the money I'll be your
server what can I get you don't trust
her kick her ass fight yeah Crush her
skull the casino's director of security
so here the 110 what's left of us now
Sanchez and Orosco talk about you guys
all the time Lin Monroe what's up we
have reason to believe they might be
dead how can I help these numbers mean
anything to you not offhand what about
the phrase 650 and 100K each what's this
all about we think Sanchez and Rosco may
have been looking into a $65 million
gambling
scam well in that case your 650 could be
rigged slot machines or fixed hands of
poker but at 100K per hand that' be
incredibly high stakes yeah am so this
is like Oceans 11 we're not missing a p
any what about your competitors I can
ask around see if anyone knew what
Sanchez and Orosco were working on that
might narrow it down for you while
you're at it run these names oh this
might take a few hours where you guys
stand don't know yet well then please
allow me not necessary I know any
friends of Sanchez and Orosco don't
trust this guy yeah I don't trust
anybody looks like all we have available
is a sweet I guess that'll have to do
what an [__] we'll be fine at a motel
once office to comp you a site just say
yes Jack
sweeter I bet this place has a spot
we're taking spits di on The oan View oh
my God Christian Gray used to live here
trying to SED
him no suspect suspect
it no but we saw his schedule though it
was booked up I believe the guy I
believe everyone you're pregnant no [__]
no no she's engaged but you didn't know
someone finally last Ed our little
Philly
a didn't Jack unrequited love you guys
can uh unsave the date seriously yeah I
mean you know me I've always been a
numbers gal land said to get married at
a certain age certain year certain hour
certain time certain minute text
messages were from his niece who was
visiting a I realized that when I
thought he was cheating you're relieved
I was relieved I mean he's a decent man
I don't know if you're going to try to
hide your Glee Jack gleacher we don't
you want to feel excitement a little
jolt of waiting 6 years to find my wife
cheating and I was pissed good for you
Carla Dixon doesn't settle thank you a
corporate world doesn't seem that
different from the Army and that always
felt a little like a cage just didn't
know anything else then one day I was in
a bar and someone plays how and wolf
singing about trains going by in the
night yeah there you go that sounded
like real freedom to me jumping on
freight trains like Box Car Willie
that's what he does mostly I take buses
or hitchhike Jack train car where do you
eat I steal pie off window
sills sometimes people who pick me up
share a meal with me sometimes I share
with them where you sleep cheap motels
mostly oh oh oh oh oh oh unattended
boats and marinas are good for a night
flat beds of parked trucks had a great
night's sleep in a hammock I spotted in
some guy's backyard once till the
sprinklers went off a there's a jack
sprinkler don't you ever get lonely a
jack loner I got my Diner drive that so
bad I know I didn't really need that
scene yeah we did boy characters
character work really needed it yeah
this is where where Jack hobo Reacher
comes in handy
yes oh you can eat there's think we
spend the day here and then we'll
investigate chanes and all that
later the week to maintain maybe hit the
gam four times
today feel like they do make a point in
the show of showing how much he eats
Jack feeder just naturally goes into his
muscles just directly directly like
popey he spinach need to actually
weightlift looks like I'm not the only
one who couldn't sleep members relax me
f if I was going to do math I might as
well make some walking around money Jack
numbers Blackjack Reacher I could double
down and risk it all for potentially
larger payout or that was a freeze frame
next card out of that shoe was going to
bust you my grandmother was said pigs
get fat Hogs get slaughtered she's no
hog Jack hoger
15 too
many you're having a very lucky night
maybe you'd like to celebrate with a
concert on us whoa Tiffany and Taylor
Dane performing their biggest hits if
you hurry you can actually catch a
second half but I'm having fun get the
hell out of my table we know you County
cards which isn't illegal if you do it
in your
head use those muscles and help me carry
these to the cashier window you can give
these tickets to the guy in the members
only jacket looks like you would enjoy
some 80s
Ladies [__] it's what you get Pit Boss
oh she knows the cops she knows it's
watching startup costs are
prohibitive first step's always the
hardest is that why back in the day you
and I never happened a jack stepper how
much did you drink back at the hotel
room enough to ask you that question I
mean come on rard it's not like I didn't
drop any hints like let's go to dinner
let's literally have a date please I was
your boss wouldn't have been right well
I waited years for that answer and it's
pure rer yep yep so can I ask you
another question Jack answer what do you
want to do about the two guys that are
following us Jack Peter Jack
beer see that car parked up the street
with the New York dealer tags pretty
sure it was behind us on the expressway
when we came into town also pretty sure
when we walk by it the man with a gun
will step out then when we turned around
the guys behind us won't be so far
behind anymore the hottest homeless man
ever yeah I might go over the
fence
go yeah damn giving him a
boost whoa
whole fence comes
[Music]
[Laughter]
down Jack climber we open fire in a
residential area cops get called you get
locked up let's do this without guns I
think the key to this show is pair up
Jack with a with a hot woman yes who can
match his wit yeah but is also super
resourceful in her own unique way and
who call on his [__] not a damel in
the stress yeah yeah
yeah I'm going to beat these dudes down
with a crane
[Music]
oh no cement concrete
shoes Mr observant cannot observe that
yeah a little foot away from interesting
and is not going to do anything about it
what can you do about
it
[__] or maybe it's a intentional
Diversion the way he looked at it did
not seem in but he's like I could use
this yeah n that was not
intentional trying to give benefit the
doubt to my
man
who wo ow Jack
beder
ow oh God that's the way to kill a man
Jack cinder
block
no rhyme
there Cinder starts it off you can add
on no just that what the Happ just
stabing the crotch with a with a pallet
knife funny the cement blocks are
actually made like some type of foam to
protect the guy's stman
[Music]
fault it's not Jack using it but Jack
crowbar oh
the leg wrap around oh my God yeah do
the Black Widow
move oh ah shove his face in there yes
Walk of Fame that is a very wet cement
pile you're dead damn rer when we were
kids we just wrote our names in it it's
the mem's only Jackie guy from the
casino if they went after us they might
go after nean O'Donnell too they're not
going to go into a busy hotel with
cameras everywhere no ID let's search
this asshole's car maybe you can bang in
the car jack back
catar looks like someone did their
homework Jack teacher is it done not in
the way you expected oh [__] hey Jack
revealer you're with the wrong guy
Reacher this guy have heard every line I
know you should know that this hasn't in
well for you then why are you the one
that sounds scared
I'm not scared you're scared you're
scared I got all the power on this call
scene
block star 67 plates V's been scratched
off these guys are Pros should have left
one of them alive yeah he didn't give us
much of a choice did they maybe they
didn't have to suffocate that one weak
man in cement yeah a man parking lot
pass he got the unbreakable treatment
new H Technologies stamped yesterday
morning than it's what you call a clue
I'm getting a clue I'm thirsty want to
get a beer
oh Jack suture let's go would you like
to help me clean my ab wound it's like
new age is an aerospace company any ties
to Atlantic City not that I can see
headquarters are based in New York
bandage of that one AB is there boob
okay a piece of shrapnel bit me notice
with all the adrenaline pumping oh my
God got the shrap
out
Jack Jack clean her what
you yeah H Jack mommy Jack mother
yes
thanks a these
two
oh in AER It's Perfectly Normal to be
long this in vibes
aight
oh thanks I want a
cuddle Jack
rer oh yeah Jack employer oh my golly
yes a these two he can't be on top he
would destroy her
yes I will physically rendy
you it's good their power Dynamic rush
you f through that
bad ripped in half like a phone book 20
miles outside of Denver Colorado in
Colorado you love
Colorado all 650 will be in the
truck there are at least two good Ambush
points marked on the route it's a clue
he's working his way across the country
they'll all be used overseas I was told
that was the deal absolutely kill him
truck driver won't be harmed of
course I would never harm anyone oh oh
you sociopath you we need to talk to you
about what happened last night oh the
whole hotel heard what happened last
[Applause]
night thin walls but when I was looking
into things ATL City PD told me that two
more bodies have been discovered in
Upstate New York near where they found
your other friend judging by the
decomposition they've been there a while
hug got a copy of the police report for
you he can just get that well he's a
powerful casino owner guy he could get
anything he won them in a game of
cards oh no it is him oh he that tattoo
he's got the tattoo unless somebody
removed the tattoo when he joined the
army his sister was terrified he'd be
killed with some disfiguring wounds said
his dog tags could be blown off to Cal
her down he got his name and service
number tattooed across his back looked
ridiculous he didn't care he loved his
sister that light their wounds match
fronies meaning he was tortured and
tossed out of a helicopter woof no one
using any of the names you gave me Rosco
and Sanchez they weren't working on
anything for any of them no one has hit
any of the casinos you don't have
anything to worry about nework ghost
tags New York parking pass it's all new
yor
York
oh poor
Orosco where the hell you
going back to New York we're going to
need more
guns
whoa
sheepers I didn't realize that neie had
such a seral
thing just had two cereal t-shirts and
was eating a different cereal just now
it's crazy someone much serial product
placement
oh no this ends right now Calvin if you
wanted to just tell me what you figured
out and who else knows it we've already
got a beat on your buddies in Atlantic
City so you're not saving them by not
talking d a hard
bargain that's where he started started
saying the f word a bunch you're done
with this okay trying to be
[Music]
polite God bringing back some of that
harshness
Jesus so just he did it yeah guess
you're just going to tell us reer is
right the man was tortured
beforehand oh bloody yeah but he was
still dropped out
alive I'm so funny I'm just thinking
about what the big guy's going to do to
you that's cool
yeah you and us both that's really cool
yeah big guy who the hell was he talking
about title smash come on yeah nice
I'll take the 17 two 19s that veretta
and three burners once you apply for
your permit there's a 7-Day waiting
period before you can purchase a firearm
you can only buy one in a 30-day
window rules say you can lend these
Firearms to a friend which as you know
is one of the conditions for legal
temporary transfer under New Jersey Law
nice to meet you friend I'm Joe
Gordon legal temporary transfer between
family and friends can only be used for
sporting purposes so I assume you're
going to be target shooting yeah of
course hunting a combination of both
training for Hollywood picture Firearms
be back within an 8- hour period
technically every moment in time exists
within an 8 Hour
[Music]
periods can only be used in the presence
and supervision of the legal owner and
that would be me join the team
buddy how about you be with me in spirit
Frank that's 100
right there there's more where that came
from well if it's good enough for God
it's good enough for
me God loves money and how much for some
of these guitars all I'm saying is I
want to use my own personal sidearm okay
I want this to be traceable to me you
really want to get busted shooting
people with a gun registered in your
name fine but I don't got to like what
does he contribute to the team exy he's
cool he's got great drips he's sexy as
kind of like Sam Rockwell we don't know
Swan's dead not for sure swans is dead
as is his dog the dog I think I found
what we need JD's Motel Bel Parkway it's
perfect I feel like the music is so
overpowering at this season a bit he
just like drowns out a lot of the
scenes you okay with staying somewhere
so
fancy I like having the music but like
it doesn't feel as meaningful as it did
last time it feels like just there's
music yeah yeah it's like David a
Suicide Squad which he definitely
intended to have that particular kind of
sound I'm talking about the air cut guys
yeah definitely even more pop songs than
last
[Music]
time a this guy actually looks kind of
creepy you four wait
here you think anyone found out about
the friends you and Dixon made in
Atlantic City unless they decided to
report concrete Jack Friendster wake me
up if something happens whoa you taking
a nap right now I'm going to be arrested
but I got a feeling it's it's going to
take a
while Jack sleeper nap
Reacher 2 hours
later these are very interesting NYPD
officers hey Slugger get
out pay back the bail money don't forget
the run and the plane ticket what are
you waiting for get out see the
copy a kicked the hood in and beat the
[__] out of you went to law school right
yeah Ruckers so kind you can kiss my ass
this gu my lawyer a feel
[Laughter]
[__] if you separate us during transport
you'll be creating a contestable issue
that I assure you I will win on appeal
in the slim chance of conviction
actually comes to pass none of that is
remotely
accurate we can agree to disagree
Ruckers
Ruckers Jack recer hey how'd you find us
I drove around looking for the call with
a giant [__] in it I was walking here
pulled all the security footage from the
car rental companies at the airport I
saw you talking to that number in a
business suit H this guy might be an all
right guy yeah why do you have toys back
here hey put that away oh is this your
ice breakers for the kitties on the
playground that ain't even funny that's
T man it's a bag of none of your
business I'll take you care of mying
children I'm a loving [__] father
except New York and not Boston I'm Marlo
Burns New Age director of operations not
my thing but nice to meet you okay
oh this parking pass was found in a
person of interest's car we were hoping
you could provide more information about
who it was issued to and how interesting
they were thousand employees with dozens
of Divisions countless visitors coming
here every day regarding the scores of
projects we're developing who knows who
works
here this isn't just any case we're
working on the uh the victims happen to
to be our friends oh God I'll see what I
can find damn women with Personal Touch
very different from the boys want to
tell us what this is about inside your
bruised face I think it's more about his
bruised ego that was a sucker punch okay
technically the airbag sucker punched
you and when this is all over we're
going to go again and I'm going to beat
your ass to the ground well why don't
you just take off the Cuffs or send the
arrest and you guys can settle it right
here you're going to be the new Finley
what kind of lawyer are you the best The
91st ranked Law School in the country
can
produce I got bad news our friend
Sanchez and Rosco were dead kidnapped
and bodies found Upstate I heard
directly from the cas skill PD how the
hell you guys know about that guess
we're just two steps ahead of you citz
hey NYPD Blue you were actively
interfering with my investigation and if
you want me to arrest you and put you in
the tombs I can make that happen that's
not going to solve these murders and me
and you both haunting that is the one
thing we have in common h oh my God he's
going to be a good guy
kind when I looked into the 110th cin
Fran's phone logs had multiple calls to
you Tony Swan ho Sanchez Manuel arasco
but he didn't call you though why is
that I don't have a
phone you guys were in the same unit for
years now you're all being killed off
something's going on and I think you
guys know things well yeah if we share
what we've got you better have something
for us in return Jack negotiator I like
the cop our records show that parking
pass 6322 was issued to a man named
Trevor copian he's not an employee he
was here for an interview he runs an
office maintenance company washing
windows waxing floors laundering money
boring but his resume was still on file
with his
address oh we're going to Emerson Drive
650 at 100K what the hell is being sold
that's worth 65 million a sale's an
assumption in an investigation
assumptions kill $5 million a $65
million cover up a $65 million bribe
well whatever your friends were involved
in it was big enough to get them killed
65 million big that it's you who's in on
this I'm no dirty cop you followed us
without ever identifying yourself and
you brought us in here to find out what
we know but never formally arrested me
seems like you want to keep things off
the books he doesn't trust he knows
somebody well he just gave richer what
he wanted I don't take envelopes you got
that what if you need an envelope to
Maes yeah I'll touch any envelope you'll
never see me with one
deliver all documents
poisly a great way to demonstrate your
integrity would be to share some Intel
with us that we don't already know oh
91st I've seen this guy in stuff before
we got a suspect how'd you find him
printer and Fran's office we searched
that office ourselves but the memory
card was intact at the tech Geeks look
it over they found an unfinished job in
the queue it didn't print due to low
[Music]
inkari makm he's known to interpole as a
weapons broker for terrorist
organizations mmud could be who we're
looking for he's a ghost no pictures of
him anywhere Sanchez and Rosco dug this
guy up for France damn the list of
aliases we found on a flash drive that
belong to France this guy's name most
likely isn't aari mmud you were never
going to mention that
hey damn you were all that you remember
all that yeah photographic memory Jack
eats his Geno baloba we're going to need
to pull neie and the others off that
arson case what come on this is a bar R
Gun wrong past Reacher it could be a
stamp from club like you get outside the
door except on his
bomb we showed pictures of private Sims
to all the employees no one recognized
him he definitely wasn't involved in
some fight that led to this it every
inch of the place and it wasn't easy cuz
the ladies were barely letting me go by
a he was never in that bar his pant
cuffs are wet couple potholes back there
filled with last night's rain he was
running for his life got through this
lot splash the pothole got slowed down
got popped in the back I could have put
this together yep it was transferred off
something he was holding on to while he
ran look how the ink smudged came off a
glass scene wrapper he stole someone's
drugs a kite cuz it got you high
uh Lieutenant Colonel oh cut the [__]
Reacher I'm in my Wranglers for Christ's
sake so what do we have here the ever
winning combination of booze men and
guns replace booze with drugs from the
looks of a private Sim stole some ran
and got caught
oh no un your team open a file and dig
in keep me updated there's anything I
can do to help for now my but Pan's
melting and I got some drugs in the back
as well you really made an impression
it's a fighter kite saw these all the
time in Afghanistan kite fighting's
popular there so was heroin production
the aviation fuel case let's pull that
file you might know what was weighing
down all those planes and find me anyone
flying a kite right now and see if you
got any heroin on you you're quiet what
you thinking this Mor freaking cereal
I'm thinking you're going to figure out
those numbers we're going to find those
and they're going to learn exactly why
you do not mess with the special
investigators rer sure knew what he was
doing when he put us together didn't he
guys got good instincts guys got good
everything
no good
D he got the D Jack
penis I honestly thought he wasn't
interested he keeps everybody at a
distance except you I like how we are
distance is comfortable oh no so how'd
that happen no idea but I do know even
when days months even years go by
without us speaking Rachel will be there
when I need him true that that's it it's
days and months oh oh you said just the
right [__] there's seven sheets right on
each sheet there's 26 or 27 numerical
tabulations and if you run them all
together you could fit everything on one
page instead of seven but clearly they
wanted seven oh yeah the specific
calculation of data makes it even more
relevant that all of the pages have 26
except for one one has 27 what I was
going to say because did nothing since
you said oh my God just pun somebody
each page is a month but not every month
has the same amount of days but if you
work 6 days a week that totals 26 or 27
days depending on which day that
particular month starts or ends on yes
are you going to sleep with Jack
again do something I understand can we
get back to the real matter at hand
something was supposed to happen 9 or 10
or 12 or 13 times a day Monday through
Saturday but it didn't always come out
right it's not just that it didn't
always come out right that's what she
said numbers went from pretty good in
month one to abysmal in month seven what
kind of somethings were they counting
who's slacking off at work we got a
recent hit on this a. and one of the
names on the list Alexander maropoulos
just bought a ticket for a flight from
Denver to JFK that boards in in house
hour Denver soon as am checks in we got
him but he disposes of his passports
yeah it's not going to be that easy he
burns them in the bathrooms Jack burner
he's going to be able to identify anyone
who looks remotely suspicious like right
now oh no dude but everyone
suspicious this undercover guys are so
rigid oh I'm so sorry about
that you're not sorry he just stole the
whole identity I've been delayed what do
you mean delayed do I really have to
define the word delayed for you I'll
still be there just a bit later than
expected that actually did clear things
up thank you my ID is are burned how
much do you think they know if there was
a clear link between us you'd be
speaking to your lawyer right now
instead of me well you're supposedly the
expert on all this and we had a deal a
deal have you done a deal like this
before for the type of product being
purchased at the price off it are you in
over your head sir no I have like you
Americans say this is not my first rodeo
but how are you going to get into New
York with Ann
ID hey everywhere I go someone looks
like me he's going to get a cosmetic
surgery to look like that doctor who
looks like him and poses the doctor it's
One Stop Shop [__] she's right of course
she's right it's
numbers Hey sopian home sweet home can
you get me some info on that house next
door I still bet she's a bager yeah
Barbara godman she's 79 so be nice why
wouldn't I be nice I love old ladies and
old ladies love me hello is this Miss
goddman of 950 Emerson Drive yes I found
Trevor cian's wallet on the sidewalk but
I wanted to make sure he still lives
there before I mail it back picture has
a scar in his face that's
Trevor you know his trash cans have been
on the curb for days now shut up you old
hack so it's actually his house should
go see what we can find right after we
make a stop at the hardware store got to
gear up to beat that old
lady
wowe
[Music]
whoa
W oh the nails was it a nail nail gun or
yeah nail bomb damn o oh harsh God I
would love to not do that to someone
definitely not never but you know maybe
a little bit I would never not just once
want to do that maybe twice with a
camera so I can watch it over and over
again never want to do that and get it
from multiple angles you
know this fight ooh damn dude cool shot
nice trick with The Swinging
[Music]
Door need to get alen richon on screen
who's behind the
island Michael Myers there a man with a
knife around here brought a knife to a
Reacher fight he's in the
fridge oh whoa
Jee
tactical where are the
cops oh he got the vest though man you
gota be just so well trained to be able
to fake your death like that yes slow my
heart rate
down Bonk owie prove why you're useful
this wouldn't have happened if it was my
[Music]
glock oh my goodness
nice almost got black Christmas there
boy
oh oh the brass let's go that was your
your thing that's
right oh pregnancy
shot throw shooting at his
chest good shot Mr Meo nice cover
bulletproof vest I wish I didn't keep
shooting at HIS bulletproof vest yes if
only I had shot a little above or a
little below
vest C drive into the front
door throw your gun at the
car shoot the tires
out but they shouldn't enter there oh
no oh this guy's definitely in over his
head oh my God it's a ferris buer
yes I wait L I don't do cardio yeah I'll
throw a grill at him I'll ride the
barbecue
[Music]
and it's just some random guy wanted to
get away from the
explosion who sent you Brian Collins who
do you work for New Age oh don't tell me
are you having a heart attack
yeah oh my hey oh Collins who's running
this operation Jack em te first
resuscitate him yeah bring him back
you're going to crush his chest with
those
compressions
[__] medic get this man a medic that
is so funny guy in the car was from New
Age found an ID well I'm glad you found
something cuz these guys ain't got Jack
[__] Jack
[Music]
[__] bet you wish you had a change of
clothes now huh one pair of slacks Jack
pants Reacher slack Reacher yes what
were you thinking we were thinking we
were being set up there were Hitmen who
tried to kill us in Atlantic City they
failed oh but they had a parking pass
for a company called New Age so you were
never going to mention that while
odonnell and I were being unlawfully
detained by you where the director of
operations gave them the name and
address of the person the past was
issued to an assassin left his address
this guy is such a New York cop yep so
you four guys just decided to walk into
a place where you knew people were
waiting to kill you well in our defense
we did blow it up first yes we got
confirmation this all goes through New
Age so you get this from the guy you
shot blew up or the asso who died by
barbecue he was stopped by barbecue he
died from trans fats ouch man don't
shame the guy poor actor he died for
trats fets the guy who died in the car
was Lee Child oh of course of course has
to be after what we did tonight it's
going to be tough for us to work the
case if the cops get on to us and not on
once I heard the description of the per
I race down it and I got official
statement from Mrs godman oh D let's
just say I didn't get a all your
Dimensions correct in my report heyy I
don't like doing that no cuz you're not
a dirty cop I don't take envelopes I
don't take any envelopes I don't go to
the post
office I don't even know what a stamp is
Don't Bring Me Postage I don't know
nothing about that let me give you a
number so you don't have to come around
where you're not want it every time you
need to talk and you don't have to mail
me using an envelope it's not mine
belong to someone I killed I killed
about someone i k cared K killed about
I'm serious no more Cowboy [__] yeah
okay think you're in charge what are we
going to do now boss saddle up maybe
it's him cuz we're about to do a whole
lot of cowboy
[__] put your Park two clicks down the
road on the right assignments cver room
H Char director of operations office
I'll take everything
else to be safe no more than 2 minutes
to get what you can IM me to Dix's car
and if I'm late don't wait for me I'll
take down the whole police force no I
love you Reacher he's going to die this
[Music]
episode oh Jack ski
mask oh my
god oh this is a crazy shot Dam yeah
holy [__] this is a great
stor Let's go
Team wow they like 5 seconds later did a
bunch of cowboy [__]
yeah
wowe
music they got to make it look like a
regular breaking and
entering take the
picture Jack picture he notices things
on
[Music]
walls of course no I'm not leaving him
here I don't want to go either but I
don't Define an order from Jack Reacher
he said go we go he's going to kill all
of us if you don't go
stop you were gonna leave without me
can't believe you were going to leave
me
[__] get going before you're all
[Music]
arrested burn everything we stole
yeah Stick it to
him holy [__] it's
Swan was working in New Age damn with
the people who've been trying to kill us
at two Swan that's a reveal yeah oh well
he was just clearly undercover yeah
climbing the ranks yeah he was just
doing what needed to be done all
right
jeez Aloha reject Nation Greg here so as
many of you guys know most of my days
are a couple of hours of filming and
then most of the time it's dedicated to
like editing and a bunch of other
computer work often accumulating to like
10 to 12 hours a day and on top of that
comfort food is like my life biggest
Vice but as many of you also know
working out and getting healthier has
been a massive component for me this
year in particular so in this Whirlwind
I have found myself a perfect Ally for
quick healthy meals America's number one
meal kit a meal kit that I have
subscribed to prior to ever agreeing and
working with them so yes this is a
genuine testimony and that is of course
for hello fresh and hellofresh is in
just about ease about bringing health
and flavor to your doorstep in this
holiday season forget about the stress
of planning meals for your health
conscious friends friends like me who
will breathe down the back of your neck
being like I can't eat that that's
unhealthy so with hello fresh I'm
looking forward to hosting holiday
dinners that are not only delicious but
also cater to Healthy Lifestyles best
part the variety it is incredible I'm
pescatarian so they have these delicious
meals just like dejon onion crunch
salmon over lemon broccoli spaghetti and
from my more plant-based days the vegan
Maple carrot power bowls they aren't
just meals they're culinary Adventures I
learned the word culinary during a long
day the last thing I want to do is spend
a while cooking and that that's where
helloof Fresh's 15minute meals are a LIF
saer they're quick nutritious and Oho
tasty perfect for my non-stop lifestyle
so why not join me in making this
holiday season both health conscious and
delicious with hellofresh with over 45
recipes and seasonal add-ons to choose
from every week there's always something
new to try and here's something to cheer
about go to hellofresh.com reex free and
use code reject free for free breakfast
for life is that accurate that sounds
way too good to be true there's no way
that can be true go to hellofresh.com
reject free and use code reject free for
free breakfast for Life One breakfast
item per box as long as your
subscription is active tag your
hellofresh trations with # hellofresh
pick and at hellofresh and let's cook up
some fun and healthiness reject Nation
remember it's America's number one meal
kit hey reject Nation you know running
real rejects is an incredible journey is
something I am truly grateful for but I
got to be real with you for one second
here managing the business side
especially taxes to put it lightly is
incredibly overwhelming it's like
navigating a maze without a map and
that's where our sponsor rocket money
comes in a sponsor when approached I was
so excited to work with because I kid
you not just last month I started using
rocket money cuz I needed to sort out
this financial puzzle and honestly it's
been quite eye-opening not just for
taxes but boy oh boy that whole cliche
of this app is true I discovered absence
subscriptions I have been paying for
that I had not used in ages it is like
finding out you've been leaving lights
on in a room that you never use so yes
rocket money isn't just another app it's
like a freaking Financial Guardian Angel
it finds and cancels those forgotten
subscriptions monitors your spending and
even battles to lower your bills thank
God it's as if they're personally
invested in saving your hard-earned
money like I try I really try to be on
top of my expenses rocket money they
show me blind spots with a simple tap I
can cancel unnecessary subscriptions
they even hand the hassle of negotiating
with customer services a relief my
goodness to put it into perspective
rocket money has helped over 5 million
users save an average of $720 a year
that's more than just numbers it's a
piece of mind so I invite you my fellow
Rejects and taking control of your
finances so go ahead visit rocket
money.com rejects once again that's
rocket
money.com rejects let's save together
money.com rejects I really do stand by
this app thank you for partnering with
us
jeez Jesu Christ well John what' you
think I enjoyed these episodes I think
the third one was my favorite uh but I
do well I don't know actually now that
you have challenged me on this off the
Dome thought I just threw out here maybe
recency bias is s i mean Atlantic cities
was really you know wow didn't think I
get so much push back on this well you
know I mean that suggests to me that
maybe you like the second episode better
thought so really I mean
yes I like these both I I thought that
they
progressively uh started to synthesize
the flavors of Jack Reacher that make
the show reach or what it is or at least
what I associate well I don't know you
know I think maybe it's all falling
apart and uh this is the worst episode
uh I've seen yet why don't you low my
mic you know sure
no of course my be uh yeah no I I
liked the totality of these two episodes
I think I like them both better than the
first one just in terms of like impact
and enjoyment
of got massage the microphone sure this
is ASMR for you
guys M should I make sure uh-huh
sorry I sorry about that don't be sorry
ever I liked that in the second episode
we got more uh we got a group scene with
everybody just chilling out and then we
got some personal time with uh with what
is her name again I need to commit it to
memory the one who you suspect who is
the numbers oh the lady yes call that
there's a hot one yep uh I liked getting
sub NE and the hot one neie and the hot
one not to talk to ne's good looks and
uh and and then there Sam Rockwell guy
prettyy pretty boy and uh Jack Reacher
Jack Reacher and well you know and then
there's Orosco and and Sanchez and uh
I'm tense and Frenchie or whatever his
name is and yeah and then there's New
Yorker cop New York cop uh anyhow uh
yeah I don't know by the third episode
it felt a bit more like the balance
finally of the was you know just kind of
lived in little nuances and stuff like
that or at least getting closer to that
distinct flavor that the first season
had uh with the you know
atmospherics and the character beats uh
but also continuing you know this
mystery and why do you want to just be
the first season John why can't you just
accept the fact that this is a different
season you know just like the books the
books they take place in different
locations and different flares and
different ensembles Jack Reacher is the
constant and I guess NE and child writes
every book like it's just totally
different
author uh yeah
I I'm just uh I'm so compelled by your
your spa day over here spa day it's okay
I mean it's not the same obviously but
can you imagine sure at a massage or
something like that everyone's thumbs
break yeah no one can go hard enough on
those knots um but yeah I don't know the
mystery is mounting I think it's
interesting that we have met you know
the puppet puller the the string puller
Puppet Master already and is a character
who does not seem in as much control as
like the heavy from last season I think
it's an interesting position to put a
Robert Patrick in where he seems uh you
know certainly at the outset like a he's
a menacing kind of guy but the more we
learn about him the more it seems like
oh you're not maybe uh as experienced
with this stuff as you want to appear
here as being uh which is kind of a neat
thread uh yeah I don't know three
episodes and I feel a bit more
solidified than I did at the end of the
first episode because the first episode
did feel very much like all right we got
this gang together and we're and we're
doing the plot we're doing the mystery
we're doing all that stuff but uh I've
been yeah just looking forward to the
more nuanced flourishes the show is good
at and I feel like those are mounting
with each Progressive episode to some
degree what did you think
G well I think compared to the first
season everything must be compared to
the first season it must
be uh no I don't have it compared to the
first season I think the show's good I
think it's okay right now I'm not in
love with it same I really because the
way you spoke about it just seemed like
the most positive [__] I've ever
heard nothing could be more posit I
liked these episodes and I like it the
you know I I've increasingly liked it as
we've watched watched it but I won't
pretend that I am as enthralled or
joyous about what yeah how it kind of is
presenting at the moment as compared to
the first season that Immaculate first
season Cru
movies it was a pretty great first
season I can't deny that it was pretty
special
uh yeah yeah yeah like uh right now
there's it this show right now uh just
taking on its own Merit because really
there's no connection to the first
season not at all they don't even
acknowledge really those character which
is what I sort of expected yeah I
expected that this what they would do so
I I want to kind of Judge it just based
off of um the show itself I think the
when when drawing comparisons to the
first season that is to say that the
first season just felt like it's a very
unique type of Gothic
Southern Gothic investigative Mystery
Show yeah with uh an ensemble of
characters that really shined Beyond
Jack
Reacher and here you've got the setting
of New York which doesn't really feel
palpable or east coast I would say like
they got Atlantic City in New York um
and and I don't really get the and I
thought like okay maybe they should
embody some of that a little bit more
because like City and
environment the first season had music
tracks this has music tracks but except
there're just kind of here um first
season has fight scenes this has fight
scenes and they're good here they don't
feel as special they feel more requisite
yeah yeah uh
and the first season had Jack Reacher
you got Jack here and they have an
ensemble and last one they have an emble
here and so it's like this similar
pieces different looks for sure I I
guess I just don't find the
mystery um like sure do I want to know
find out what happens yeah sure why not
uh that's what you
want but to its
defense um I remembered being here with
you in the first season being like yeah
I'm not that intrigued by like the
mystery itself is not really the main
appeal it's it's h everything
surrounding the mystery that that is
truly the appeal of the show yeah it's
the atmosphere and the characters and I
can't say that for this one uh so far I
think the
Ensemble I love the context of it I love
the idea of the characters yeah people
from Reacher's past instead of Reacher
being like solo cool mysterious guy he
gets to share some of the burden here
share some of the grief here uh like
both like physically and literally
sharing the grief the load of the grief
and uh people who he's like close with
from his past instead of uh you know um
wander amidst
strangers and yet and while I think the
chemistry with everyone is pretty good I
think everyone's chemistry is pretty
good and I believe the history like I I
believe they all have known each other I
don't just feel like they're just actors
cast yeah who are slapped together in a
room to pretend like they've known each
other like I I buy that uh I can't quite
place my finger on it yet it still seems
like um kind of a typical show now it
doesn't quite sing of uniqueness other
than it it feels like a network TV show
that has an R-rated flourish once in a
while like oh there's f-words here oh
it's a little more violent than I than
you would see on network TV uh like
General Network TV like don't get me
wrong Network TV can at like 10 p.m slot
shows they can go pretty freaking
violent you
know then but here they won't go f bombs
you know and and that's that's about and
then once in a while I do like a a cool
thing that I'm like surprisingly really
cool you know like with the backing into
the parking
lot uh that way they they capture that
shot like I I prefer when they do
something that does embody a little bit
more of the atmosphere of the snow
falling and stuff like that or or even
getting like a super New York cop super
New York detective like I really like
that as much as it's like kind of funny
that you have like just the most New
York detective new yorkest detective to
ever detected New York there's it it
helps lend a distinguishability between
this season and last and adds a real
personality and flavor and I think with
its main Ensemble of characters as much
I like I like the Atlantic City hotel
bonding
scene I think one of them needs to get
killed off a little bit earlier one of
our main core probably yeah because I'm
like I mean you got the four of you guys
together it's pretty like got like other
than Jack Reacher like yeah he's like
Jack Sledgehammer I get it but you know
there essentially for Jack reers yeah
you all have similar skills abilities
you're you're four Jack reachers and you
and each one of you just has like okay
like hot girl is is uh you know more
enhanced with numbers yes then the other
ones yeah they're all just Jack reachers
with a special skill yeah like what but
they all share similar skills yeah like
they fight the same they they think as a
unit they think yeah and so uh I guess
they really need to sell us it would be
more compelling if they really sold us
on the danger and the threat other okay
a couple of them were killed off we
didn't really know them so it would be I
think it would have helped just kind of
like flipping some perspective here or
allowing or or certain buildup to them
coming together as a unit it again like
you don't mess with the special
investigator like well could have used a
little bit more of a bill to these guys
instead of like you can't just throw
that in here without feels like a bit of
a meme slogan that they told us it feels
like we were recounted the anecdote but
didn't quite get like The Full
Experience to where we are now clued in
on you know I don't know the the true
charm and earning of the you don't mess
with the special investigator
sentiment yeah yeah yeah so there it
does feel like there's some missing
pieces here or or like it feels to me
like it feels like something written by
different people or like a different
creative voice guiding the show and I
don't know if they had any switch UPS in
their writer room but I feel like they
started tending to I don't know I don't
I don't know the books and I and I don't
like it's not it's the it's the thing is
like it's just not it's not bad it's
just not as compelling or as interesting
as or as fun or you know there's a lot
of a lot of every adjective I can think
of I'm like it's all there just on less
of a higher level well the thing at
least to me here in this moment uh not
to not to keep going back to the fs but
like uh what seems different to me is
that this feels more like it's being
written
like this kind of show if that makes
sense like it's being written more with
the sentiment of like let's give more
cool lines and let's have them like kind
of Quip each other in a way that feels a
bit more heightened like that again was
always there but it feels like they're
writing it more like some kind of
tactical
Thriller rather than like the the first
season seemed to be like oh this is this
feels like it was written to be like
some sort of literary Gothic mystery
that happens to feature a soldier who is
highly trained and who can you know
level anybody there's like a new ish
quality to that it feels like you're
yeah you're following some kind of
anti-hero and there are multiple genres
at work but it presents as some kind of
military procedural Thriller uh and this
feels like it's mostly just trying to be
a military procedural Thriller and kind
of isoing the other things that it was
so Charming at being and that made it it
kind of reminds me of the piece of
advice people say it's like if you want
to write a genre watch a bunch of
different or read a bunch of different
genres read other stuff outside of that
and bring that into your genre and where
I'm feeling right now is mostly like
this was mostly just fed on the same
kind of stuff that this is trying to be
it's it's incredibly straightforward
yeah um to the point where it just loses
just like taken aback by that yeah it
loses it loses a lot of its personality
to me and and it makes the characters
feel less alive yeah like I this this
core of characters when they're all like
really quipping with each other I'm like
y all sound the same and maybe you're
trying to tell me that's the point that
you all think a lot cuz you're one unit
uh but there should be some subtle
differences if you were all such an
you're but at the same time you're like
you're a you're a show you're a movie
you're like I would hate to watch like
Oceans 11 or something you be like they
all sound exactly the same like no I
come here to watch like distinguished
personalities interact with each other
yeah totally you know and for the most
part you're you're all you all sound the
same and and it it does make it feel
like the It doesn't feel alive makes it
feel less alive and it makes like it's
it's just not as exciting and and right
now I am I'm that's that's the thing is
like I'm not I'm not bored I'm just not
as invested as as perhaps I would like
to be like I
think look guys it's a season 2 so
you're naturally going to compare it
especially when you're not a book reader
of the in general like just like books
no well when the first season was such a
surprise well you I think Rosco yeah and
Henley and Finley Finley yeah Rosco and
Finley like black detective who they
keep bringing up like why are you a
black detective here and then Rosco with
her history to the town who could just
be a generic cop character those two are
way more interesting to me than than
anyone we met SC group like they are way
more interesting well and and he and
neie like neie was such an interesting
presence and an interesting facet to add
partway through the season there in the
first when you're ju oppose her with
everyone else though yeah yeah exactly
there's contrast and it's like I think
there's a way to make it work with a
bunch of people who share who are cut
from the same cloth and who share a
bunch of like experience it's like the
first season had all the flashbacks and
I felt like those even though those
served to function in the present
timeline of the story I felt like we
were spending time getting to know Jack
Reacher throughout that and I feel like
the flashbacks here ought to serve a
similar purpose and they kind of do but
they still feel more like information
delivery than they do like let's dive
into the character for a second and
develop them I don't know it just
doesn't feel like there's much of a
character story beyond the plot no
there's not and that's that's exactly
what I was trying to bring up earlier
was that it w the first season I
remember the mystery being kind of
whatever to like like I I kind of am
interested in the mystery but I'm it's
everything around the mystery that makes
the show so great yeah the mystery is
cool but like it's all about the plot
the investigation and I'm like but the
personalities of the characters I'm not
loving like I I I'd rather be here just
because I like Jack Reacher yeah I like
what this show does so I'm willing to
give the benefit of the out and to give
a while to see where they take this and
i' I'd ra yeah I would I will gladly
wait but you know when you do a three
episode
premiere I expect to I I'm naturally
just I wish I was more well hooked by
everything that's happening but right
now yeah I'm not like chomping at the
bit to watch episode 4 I'm not yeah I I
don't think it's unfair to ask C I don't
know cuz the things we keep comparing to
are broad I I don't think it's unfair to
be like I should feel the time and place
and I feel like New York Atlantic City
these are places that beg that have
their own personality that have their
own life we should feel like we're there
in the music like they clearly are
making a point to have it so like make
it meaningful like you did the first
time or at least clue Us in somehow
rather than just having them talk over
it and me going I like that there's
music because that's kind of realistic
but also the sound mix is a little bit
like it's I'm not focused on the right
thing right now and uh yeah I just don't
think it's unfair to ask for those
things when that's what set the show
apart initially was the tone the
atmosphere the place the characters oh
and hey it just so happens there are
great striking fights it's the other
thing too is like the fight scenes are
are fine but in the first season there
were moments where tons and tons of
moments where it's like there was
distinctive impactful and I don't know
just sort of like less chop chop and
it's not even the the action here is
shot or edited poorly it's just like
there was something that was almost like
Sumptuous about it the first time it was
really pronounced and it really crunched
and like it does in the moment like I
think him kicking in the hood of the car
is the most impactful piece of that uh
here and even the villains and stuff
like that's like I think it's a cool
subversion that we know that Robert
Patrick is at least you know pretty much
behind this or is a big player in this
but you know the first season also has
that contrast where they build up at
least the villains with some pretty
horrific like murder scenes and you're
investigating that stuff and being like
wow they they nailed this guy to a wall
that's really Stark and upsetting you
know and there's not really much of that
kind of thing either really like even
when it goes back I remember we had a
moment in one of these episodes where we
like oh that's right they do some messed
up stuff sometimes on this show I don't
even really feel like that is gonna
happen or if it does happen I'll be kind
of like oh that's right whereas before
it felt like yeah those things would
just happen appropriately at times when
yeah you're coming across a crime scene
or in the midst of some kind of scuffle
or whatever I don't
know I hate you I hate
you but not as much as I hate anything
that's not season one of
Jack what do you guys think are you just
as satisfied as you were before uh yeah
I'm a little tired I'm a little tired
now oh I'm a little more nap Reacher I'm
I'm willing to I'm willing before I cast
a full judgment on it I would rather
wait because I'm like Show's done enough
good yeah and um there's enough
qualities I'm reading for him but right
now everything's just sort of it's
decent because this could very well be a
first season that's my that's my points
like and and if this was a first season
and I and I feel like you can do that
with Jack from what I know about Jack
Reacher the novels from even watching
the movies like yeah every new one is
like a a new start yeah new thing new
story they're episodic for the most part
yeah and and I other than some
characters can carry over you know you
can sometimes it could just be a new
jumping off point for someone they don't
have to start at the first Jack Reacher
book you know yeah it could be yeah you
could start with any of these here are
the best ones you might be interested in
trying yeah cuz I from my understanding
not even like the first season is based
off of the first book right yeah it's I
guess like I don't know whatever and
same thing here so my point being with
that is if this was a first season yeah
I'd be like it's fine this is about what
I expected a Jack Reacher show to be
don't really need to watch the rest of
the like yeah whereas yeah where here
I'm like I'm continuing it because I
really love the first season the first
season such an impression I'm really
holding out here and defied so
beautifully the expectation of what you
thought it would be and frankly the last
thing I'll say is that on the idea of a
unit is cool but at the same time that
kind of strips away what makes Jack
Reacher special is that he is the he is
that you you ruin the specialty when
because the idea is you place this
special anomaly of a military human
being buff dude in with this crazy
Sherlock Holmes mind in the middle of
like
normaly yeah when you got like four of
them you kind of and then you're
following that and he's accompanied by
that sometimes he's even asking
questions to the group where I'm going I
feel like Jack richer would know that
know this yeah but he has to ask it now
because he's with a group and and I
think something I don't think that
couldn't work but I think that's
definitely the hazard is yeah now jack
isn't as special of a presence because
they're a bunch of people who can do
what he does and probably have a similar
mindset but also they haven't really at
least yet in the present day it's like
in the past you at least have the
hierarchy and you know the dynamic of
his leadership whereas here they're all
kind of on equal footing well it's like
well the other thing too is Jack Reacher
is you know like he's The Drifter he
like doesn't have many money yes
different identity yeah you know he's
got he's got still got a scrap whereas
here is kind of like he's taken care of
yeah he's got everyone taken care of him
that's why I'm like you got that's why
I'm saying I feel like you got to kill
off one of the four
earlier on create some problems you got
you got to really put them in a bind or
something like that cuz cuz right now
there's when I boil it down to something
really simple at the simplest if you
made it this far is I don't feel any
tension and I don't feel any Stakes so
when you don't have those qualities
which is like the driving force the most
basic driving force of any television
other than like right now all I got is
um Baseline find likability for
everything and nothing is egregiously
bad he needs to go talk to the gun guy
more so we can have any other character
who's just like a person in town yeah
sure yeah cuz that was one scene that
kind of reminded me of of some of the
lovely types of character moments
Reacher can provide and I mean not that
it's the best one but well that's why I
like the scene with him being arrested
in the cop because um that puts him out
of his power position and a it's a game
of power dynamics again and and it's fun
to see the cop actually arise as a
character that we can like and Trust
yeah and that was a nice version where I
thought he might have just been another
bad guy following as well or he could
have been a crooked cop yeah and so but
I'm like oh I really believe this guy is
is a good guy yeah and I like the the
guy the am guy they're chasing around
the country sort of but I feel like
because he is also a type A Trope of
like you know calm collected laconic
Hitman guy I feel like that again you
need some contrast to really sell that
so that it doesn't just feel like a born
you know pull or something like that
yeah yeah that's
true I don't know they got all they need
to to cook with I just hope that they
they kick it up a notch yeah for real
man Emerald legassi put some more
seasoning on this it's a very
workmanlike meal right now all righty
guys leave your thoughts down below what
you think about Jack Reacher season 2
premieres uh much love to everyone and
um no let's keep going at least for ourm
I mean I'm sure there's a lot of people
who really love it and still looking
forward happy you do so let's see what
it's like uh going with open minds as
the season progresses we'll see what
goes on thank you guys so much for being
here we'll talk to you all
soon all right John pick a name O let's
do this thing H let's let's do Ana Oliva
Ana you know what you're getting for
Christmas this year Ana you're going to
get two first class tickets to Houston
yes that's right you via the Dallas Fort
Worth airport where did she live in
Texas joke I would have landed this
perfectly if I remembered specifically
what city the only the only city that I
associate people I know with living in
is Austin and I don't feel like that's
right I don't think she's actually
Austin she might actually be in wait a
minute she well she got us that sand you
remember that the bottled sand which I
have on one of my shelves I don't know
where your bottle is that's right there
oh then let's maybe that is from Her
Sacred homeland of uh Port Aransas Texas
or maybe she just took a trip to Port
oranus Texas you know what you're
getting for Christmas A take two you and
on your take two you are going to be
getting a mannequin of John Humphrey
it's going to be like one of those wax
museum ones of John yes and uh we will
keep it at your nearest Arco gas station
oh yeah with the dinosaur always in the
bathroom that way with the dinosaur
don't they have a d no I'm I'm thinking
of a different station or the Pegasus
either way the gas station bathroom take
three you know you're getting this year
a Merry Christmas a Merry Christmas a
Fel Navidad and a Happy New Year and a
good time with your family Prospero Ando
if F Merry Christmas Ana we miss you we
hope to see you out here again in Port
ransaw
AR is it Oris or is it
aransa let's the problem states have
messed all this up for me and only me
take
[Music]
four